[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
je suis aujourd'hui avec Carole Pelé
chanteuse compositrice et réalisatrice
bonjour bonjour Alors Carole Pellé vous
avez une actualité dense le 25 novembre
2022 vous avez d'ailleurs sorti votre
deuxième EP alors avant d'en parler on
va parler un petit peu de vous comment
en êtes-vous arrivé à devenir chanteuse
en fait ça a été assez longue histoire
que je vais faire courte du coup
en fait moi l'origine je j'étais
journaliste et puis ensuite j'ai étudié
aux Beaux-Arts de Paris et en fait un
jour j'ai pris un cours de chant et j'ai
une révélation parce que ça faisait un
moment que je me demandais comment je
pouvais utiliser ma voix comme un
instrument un outil en fait comme un
outil de travail artistique et j'ai une
révélation et je me suis dit que tout
allait partir du chant et de là j'ai
tiré le fil et je suis devenue chanteuse
quoi alors de nombreux artistes décident
justement de s'exprimer à travers leur
musique quels sont les messages que vous
voulez transmettre à travers vos
chansons mais les messages ça serait
en fait en réalité il y a pas vraiment
de messages avec une grosse étiquette
c'est plutôt des des sensations et des
valeurs en fait ce que je transmets et
les valeurs c'est le fait de d'essayer
de voir le positif dans ce qu'il y a de
négatif de de croire en ses rêves de
garder aussi l'espoir et aussi dans la
vie d'essayer de réfléchir sur soi pour
pour avancer et pareil que comme je le
fais dans la mienne d'essayer de tirer
ce fil de se connaître soi-même et voilà
je pense que c'est ici que réside le
bonheur quoi
vous indiquez que vous livrez vos
révoltes et vos espoirs alors justement
qui est Carole Pelé est-ce que c'est une
artiste révoltée qui a beaucoup de
choses à dire ben oui je pense que j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire et ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours eu en
fait mais c'est une sensation que j'ai
toujours eu déjà parce que je réfléchis
beaucoup parce que j'analyse beaucoup ce
qui se passe autour de moi que ça soit
je suis très ouverte au monde à
l'humanité donc je me renseigne beaucoup
et puis aussi dans les comportements des
gens qui m'entourent et dans la vie de
tous les jours quoi chez moi je sens que
j'ai besoin de m'exprimer même quand je
suis toute seule je parle toute seule
pendant des heures ça ne s'arrête jamais
donc bref oui je pense qu'il y a
effectivement un bouillonnement
intellectuel qui qui se besoin
d'exprimer des choses qui qui sont au
fond de moi de me connaître et je pense
que cette connaissance là elle se
transmet aux autres et elle touche les
autres aussi en tout cas c'est ce qui
c'est l'effet que ça me fait moins dans
l'art donc c'est pour ça que je fais ça
râpez beaucoup vos chansons sont parfois
parlées vous n'avez pas choisi de nom de
scène car elle peut laisser donc votre
vrai nom pourquoi ce choix mais parce
que bon déjà c'est quelque chose qui me
semblait plutôt naturel et logique dans
le sens où quand j'étais journaliste
aussi je signais avec mon nom et mon
prénom donc c'est dans cette continuité
aussi parce que comme dans le métier de
journaliste que j'essaie de faire moins
en art c'est de de transmettre ma vision
aussi de la vérité quoi
même si évidemment c'est pas du tout
l'amitié et puis ensuite pour moi
c'était aussi une manière de ne pas
retourner en arrière quoi c'est un acte
fort d'utiliser son nom prénom civil
c'est c'est une manière d'acter d'acter
le chemin de vie aussi quoi voilà et là
lorsque vous composez quels sont vos
inspirations justement est-ce qu'il y a
des artistes qui vous passionnent dans
leur façon d'écrire de chanter ou de
s'exprimer oui bah oui il y en a je les
références la toute première qui m'a je
pense donner envie de faire de la
chanson et de me diriger vers ce style
musical ça a été fauve que j'adore il y
a aussi une artiste qui s'appelle Gaëtan
peste que j'adore après dans les
artistes qui m'inspirent qui m'inspirent
au tout début aussi Attila dans son
style après musicalement je trouve qu'il
y a quelque chose d'assez efficace dans
le piano d'Angèle aussi
et puis j'aime bien Stromae aussi dans
l'idée quoi c'est un peu les artistes
auxquels je me réfère le plus quoi ce
sont des artistes très souvent ou on a
toujours l'impression qu'ils sont
presque poétiques dans leur chanson
c'est également ce que vous recherchez
cette ce côté un peu poétique dans vos
chansons dans vos dans vos compositions
dans la poésie
ce qu'on appelle poésie parce que
typiquement dans mon écriture il y a
quelque chose qui est assez loin de la
poésie dans le sens où par exemple
j'utilise pas des rimes ou les images
aussi sont finalement très peu
fréquentes quoi
mais la poésie au sens large dans le
fait que il y a un regard qui qui
enchante le monde qui le sublime ça oui
clairement c'est un axe de travail alors
en novembre 2022 vous avez sorti votre
deuxième EP on va écouter un extrait de
si c'était Dieu et on poursuit juste
après
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'était Dieu et je reste
très prudente mais j'ai senti sur moi
une lumière blanche d'ailleurs je sais
pas si c'était Dieu et je reste très
prudente mais je me demande bien ce que
c'était avec cette lumière blanche
j'ai senti dans interruption du temps
moi le temps qui s'interrompre
j'ai sentir l'interruption du temps moi
le temps qui senti ça
est-ce que c'est ça est-ce que c'est ça
est-ce que c'est ça est-ce que ça la
vérité
est-ce que c'est ça est-ce que ça est-ce
que ça les derniers
cru en rien mais là j'ai eu très peur
très froid alors si c'était Dieu à
retrouver donc dans votre deuxième EP
quels sont vos objectifs justement à
travers cette paix qu'est-ce que vous
voulez transmettre aux gens qui vous
écoutent mais ce que je me transmettre
aux gens c'est
une sincérité c'est une émotion à chaque
fois dans les chansons c'est c'est
rentrer en connexion avec eux vraiment
par l'émotion voilà c'est
c'est en fait tout simplement ce qu'on
appelle dans la fonction cathartique
quoi c'est l'objectif de tous les
artistes c'est c'est se partagent là
c'est
schématiquement c'est le fait de de se
rencontrer de rencontrer une émotion et
de la revivre et quelque part de s'en
libérer simplement en ressentant le fait
que on n'est pas seul à lui vivre et ça
je trouve ça je trouve ça très beau quoi
alors justement si c'était Dieu quel est
le message à travers cette cette chanson
qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu dire
comment vous avez voulu vous exprimer
mais si c'était Dieu en fait ça raconte
ça raconte une sensation que j'ai vécue
et
en fait à partir de cette sensation là
je me suis demandé si c'était pas
quelque chose un peu bizarres et ça m'a
fait penser je me enfin comme c'était
une sorte de connexion avec quelque
chose qui me dépassait quoi donc je me
suis dit est-ce que ça serait pas
quelque chose de spirituel et dans la
chanson je me demande à partir de là si
Dieu existe et je pose la question aussi
aux gens Carole Pelé vous êtes avant
d'être chandeuse pardon vous êtes
journaliste vous avez également fait les
Beaux-Arts vous vous l'avez dit à un
instant à vous les avez terminé il y a
peu est-ce que c'est aussi votre
parcours justement qui vous a donné
envie de vous livrer autrement et de
vous exprimer à travers la chanson ben
est-ce que c'est mon parcours
disons que j'ai changé de voix parce que
effectivement je me suis dit que
j'analise c'était c'était pas tout à
fait ça je dirais que en fait tout mon
parcours a influencé aujourd'hui ce que
l'artiste que je suis quoi et à nourri
en fait tout ça donc je dirais que ça
communique plutôt comme ça quoi par
aussi en tant que chanteuse en tant
qu'artiste pour justement s'exprimer par
par rapport à typiquement un journaliste
qui doit être qui doit rester neutre en
fait oui c'est pas du tout le même
travail moi je pense que ce que j'ai
gardé de mon parcours de journaliste
parce que quelque part aussi ce n'est
toujours pareil mais c'est sur les
valeurs il y a des choses qui se
recroisent quand même quoi donc après
c'est aussi enfin journaliste aussi une
attitude quoi et c'est vrai que c'est
aussi aller chercher l'info ne pas
renoncer passer par la fenêtre quand on
peut pas passer par la porte enfin il y
a un peu aussi cette volonté là de ce de
se battre aussi tout le temps que que
hyper enfin qui est très important je
pense en tant qu'artiste quoi donc oui
je pense qu'il y a quand même quelque
chose qui se recoupe mais ça reste quand
même des domaines qui sont très
différents quoi il est difficile de vous
catégoriser finalement dans un genre
musical est-ce que ça aussi c'est une
part importante de votre identité
d'artistes de ne pas être catégorisé et
finalement d'être libre oui alors ça
c'est très très très important c'est
vrai que quand j'ai commencé ce ce
projet il y a quatre ans maintenant
j'ai commencé en étant vraiment dans ma
bulle moi je viens pas du tout du milieu
de la musique donc je connaissais
personne j'ai commencé au beaux-arts et
avec tous mes amis en fait on a
construit ça brick pare-brise et c'est
vrai que j'étais vraiment dans ma bulle
et donc forcément quand on est comme ça
et quand on prend pas en compte les
contraintes extérieures qui sont celles
de l'industrie et ben forcément on est
totalement libre et j'ai envie de de
rester de rester là-dedans mais je pense
que c'est en fait c'est essentiel en
tant qu'artiste d'être libre parce que
sinon ça fait toute la différence entre
quelqu'un qui est créateur et quelqu'un
qui est créatif c'est très bien d'être
créatif mais créatif c'est s'adapter
finalement à la demande s'adapter à des
normes mais c'est trop bien enfin il y a
des métiers qui sont créatifs et qui qui
fonctionnent très bien comme ça mais en
tant qu'artiste la spécificité nous de
notre métier de notre vocation c'est
d'être c'est d'être libre quoi vivre
dans la création on va finir cette
interview avec un petit peu de légèreté
je vais vous poser des questions il va
falloir me répondre très rapidement
alors par exemple votre chanson du
moment en ce moment j'écoute montagne
russe d'Aloïs sauvage une chanson à
écouter en allant au travail je mettrai
courir qui est une chanson issue de mon
deuxième EP et enfin le but ultime pour
votre carrière alors j'aimerais beaucoup
remporter une victoire de la musique
mais c'est un très beau je lance un
appel
au jury aux gens qui se sentent
concernés merci beaucoup Carole Pelé
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation donc
on peut suivre votre actualité sur votre
page Facebook Carole Pelé tout
simplement votre pète à découvrir sur
les plateformes de streaming et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]